the gyro can experience Kenny Rogers and
says that I am the worst hunter in the
world because when I moved to the
vineyard I remember the first year
everywhere out there isn't it
I didn't know that and I came home one
night lit up and I got out of my car and
I did just popped in front of the door I
backed up and stepped on a wild turkeys
foot off whatever I got it so I'm gonna
holla [ __ ] baby there's so much be this
object that broke out of it so these
animals they're not gonna live on my
property so I got a gun right and and
the squirrels read all my bird feed and
I have feed the birds and so I'd say I'm
gonna kill you bastard Jim first I was
throwing furniture at them and I got a
couple of but then I I don't want I
really want to kill him but I think I'd
like to shoot the tail off you know
maybe right but the bastards move and
I'd get him in the head I go now so this
poor sufferer and I go now look what you
made me do yeah
you stupid bashing him no nothing's good
well well yeah I give him today I give
him to the people in the neighborhood
you know but but I I don't kill him cuz
I feel bad when I get cuz I don't want
to kill him I mean I'm not one of these
didn't want to eat the bird food exactly
yeah we had a problem with our chickens
the squirrels were getting into the
chicken coop and chicken food well the
deer not a deer my wife's worth they had
a total dick a tea caddies gone
uh-uh yeah so the other night I'm coming
home I be not to swerve is what I go for
him I chased the past it's all I Jason
might well feel I didn't get him but but
you could die that way too
yeah oh yeah cuz you know my friend cam
his he lives in new Eugene Oregon and a
guy in his neighborhood guy in front of
him hit a deer and it flew up in the air
and landed through his windshield and
killed him
oh yeah so guy driving down the highway
guy in front hits the deer boom Oh deer
comes flying through the air bang right
through the windshield the second guy oh
yeah guys that's where I never follow
anyone always lead legally be the lead
pony man look behind me does not matter
but with the with the deer you know when
I got there I had I had a partial view
of the ocean you know there has to be a
real ocean view and then at the time I
was
they be terrible if a typhoon came into
college trees down and the trees came
down but I replaced every tree that was
missing we brought up - I see you're
saying - nurseries of course you do
nursery step we're going out a little
Eagle to chop trees down evidently you
didn't do that I would why would I talk
I'm a law-abiding person I understand so
I bought two nurseries going out of
business
we have 500 trees not over six feet tall
but then we had gods and vegetables and
stuff like that and the deer were eating
them and I'm at the beach one day and
I'm pissed off from cease goddamn there
and it's this this old guy cut some
excuse me excuse me I overheard your
conversation this is what deer don't eat
and he gave me a list like 50 things so
I bought out and bought everything and
I'm week later I saw him hey [ __ ]
evidently my dear can't read cuz they
ate all of that and then I just so I I'm
not good at killing stuff I lie I did
kill a couple you know my mistake I
really did I try to scare me you know
they ran into the bullet as opposed to
boy you shoot him with uh well this was
a 22 like the rifleman yeah I love my
favorite men yeah I used to love that
job but I got one just like that right
yeah yeah yeah yeah I got really good
with it you know so like when I was
repeating were like a Henry rifle
exactly exactly I still make those you
know Henry rifles is like a big rifle
company Kenny came down when we kick any
Rogers and stayed up all night he
refused to sleep went through about 300
rounds and the gun was still smoking the
next morning and I gotta get it fixed
now he liked it so I have other guns but
anyway I I would call I'd call up Mike I
can't take a teammate you know you want
a day yeah I'm on my way so he came over
he's how much you kill ago oh just this
morning us do it tomorrow yeah and I go
cuz I was firing into the bushes scared
I got them so is there a rule on how
many you're allowed to kill during
season my kitchen table by the screen
door open yeah yeah
I don't I don't I don't do it anymore
but but but it's just Jay Miller I love
you know Jamie little hockey player for
the Bruins he they hide him to protect
Gretzky years ago I mean I don't think
he I think he may have lost one fight in
his life he's a tough tough son of a
[ __ ] anyway the hockey's 10th s 10 best
op fight season like three of them so he
says can I come huntin you properly I go
that'd be great
come over and kill all my dear so he
gets like six or seven guys and they
come up with these unbelievable arrows
and [ __ ]
so he's people on an Destruction they're
all these big trucks
I go hey man I'm so glad yeah God kill
everyone you can find you oh no man it's
not deer season we're killing rabbits
day and you hear my wife and I gotta go
out and tell these [ __ ] monster hunt
this is a man listen to me
my name is both of my name isn't gone
can I make kill every day every rap but
I mean imagine that you know I'm telling
he's just yeah Mexicans go down there to
kill rabbits that seems ridiculous no
all the way to Martha's Vineyard to kill
rabbit it's a lot of rabbits then
there's rabbits and skunks right and and
someone someone brought skunks are not
indigenous to the vineyard so this
[ __ ] brought skunks over because he
was pissed off it's a mother rule he
couldn't do oh man he let them and they
multiply this times easy baby skunks you
know so he brought skunks over to piss
somebody else on yep yep yes this guy
yeah I know yeah it'll come to me I'll
text them there's a few little animals
but they'll they'll [ __ ] your chickens
up to you know skunks are predators
they'll [ __ ] your dog up oh yeah yeah
you know I mean and if you got a cat
spray this [ __ ] Oh God then they gotta
bathe them in tomato juice to work my
dog got zapped he doesn't not the dog
out here the marshal but when I was a
kid my dog in Boston got zapped
yeah tomato just didn't do jack [ __ ] she
stomped for [ __ ] weeks oh yeah we
kept shampooing her yeah oh good you
know when you asked is there a limit for
the animals you can kill when I killed
my first Turkey I thought that some guy
owed all these what
fine and when there was three missing I
go he's gonna know there's three miss
he's gonna come up here and give me much
[ __ ] you know get him
[Applause]